[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Gundula
Gause und Anne Gellinek
die Durchhaltefähigkeit der Ukraine
müsse immer größer sein als die
Bösartigkeit die von Putins Krieg
ausgehe das sagte Finanzminister
Christian Lindner heute bei seinem
ersten Besuch in Kiew seit Kriegsbeginn
und fuhr auch gleich seinem Kanzler in
die Parade in dem er zu Protokoll gab er
habe große Sympathie für die Lieferung
von deutschen Taurus Marschflugkörpern
an die Ukraine Scholz hatte sich gestern
im ZDF-Interview zurückhaltend
Lindner erlebte heute einen ruhigen Tag
in Kiew während die Hafenstadt Odessa in
der Nacht wieder Ziel heftiger
russischer Angriffe wurde Kristina
Kajaks berichtet
wieder Angriffe auf die Hafenstadt
Odessa 15 Drohnen und 8 Raketen seien
abgewehrt worden meldet die Ukraine
durch herabstürzende Splitter gehen
Gebäude in Flammen auf drei Menschen
werden verletzt in saporizia werden zwei
Tote in den Trümmern eines Wohnhauses
gefunden zum ersten Mal seit
Kriegsbeginn reist der deutsche
Finanzminister nach Kiew schon am frühen
Morgen setzt er den Ton für diesen Tag
in heute mehr denn je überzeugt davon
dass die Ukraine deshalb von Russland
auch angegriffen worden ist weil sie
sich entschieden hat für die
Gemeinschaft der liberalen Demokratien
und gegen den
autoritären Stil von Putin die Ukraine
darf diesen Krieg nicht verlieren
es ist ein großes Versprechen dass der
deutsche Finanzminister hier in Kiew
gibt im Angesicht von Tod und Zerstörung
genau das was seine Gastgeber hören
möchten
Militärexperten aber warnen so einfach
werde eine Rückeroberung der besetzten
Gebiete nicht gelingen das ist nur
möglich wenn zusätzlich zu marschlupfern
auch noch Kampfflugzeuge und Kampf
Hubschrauber geliefert werden an die
Ukraine und selbst dann wird es ein sehr
schweres Stück Arbeit denn die
resilienste russischen Streitkräfte ist
sehr groß
aber auch der Wunsch der Ukraine nach
Freiheit ist groß das wird bei einem
Besuch in der symbolträchtigen ST
Michaels Kathedrale einmal mehr deutlich
in der anschließenden Pressekonferenz
kann Lindner dann auch der seit Tagen
diskutierten Frage nach der Lieferung
von Taurus Marschflugkörpern nicht mehr
ausweichen da ich weiß dass viele für
eine solche Unterstützung Sympathie
haben wie ich selbst auch hoffe ich auf
eine baldige sehr baldige Klärung dieser
Frage
in der Taurus auf dem jetzt die
Hoffnungen ruhen hat eine Reichweite von
500 km die Ukraine könnte damit auch
russisches Territorium angreifen
sollte Deutschland diesen
Marschflugkörper liefern dann ist es
noch keine Waffe die kriegsentscheidend
ist aber sie würde die ukrainische
offensivfähigkeit stärken und die
ukrainische gegen Offensive die seit
mehr als neun Wochen läuft die ist ja
nicht besonders erfolgreich gewesen
bisher und mit diesem marschflowkörper
könnte die Ukraine militärisch gestärkt
werden die Frage ist nur will man das
eskalationsrisiko eingehen dass damit
verbunden sein könnte
der Finanzminister hatte darauf heute
keine abschließende Antwort im Gepäck
aber immerhin finanzielle Zusagen und
das Versprechen die Ukraine könne sich
auf Deutschland verlassen
und aus Odessa ist uns jetzt unsere
reporterin Anne Brühl zugeschaltet guten
Abend wie ist der Besuch des
Finanzministers heute in der Ukraine
gesehen worden wird das eigentlich
registriert dass aus der Bundesregierung
beim Thema Marschflugkörper ganz
unterschiedliche Signale kommen
ja diese deutsche Diskussion die wird
hier in der Ukraine sehr genau verfolgt
weil man hier natürlich trotz allem
hofft diese Taurus Marschflugkörper auch
für die bereits laufende Offensive
einzusetzen der Wunsch ist ganz stark
und ähm von daher hält sich die Kritik
die offene Kritik in Deutschland auch an
Deutschland auch in Grenzen eines war
aber vielleicht heute dann doch
auffällig das Präsident selenski nicht
in Kiefer war sondern stattdessen bei
seinen Truppen im Osten in bachmut du
bist in odesser einer Stadt die in den
letzten Nächten schweren Angriffen
ausgesetzt war wie zermürbt sind die
Menschen vom Krieg inzwischen
ja je länger dieser Krieg dauerte der so
schwieriger wird es das ist mein
Eindruck und diese dauernden Angriffe
natürlich zermürbt das die Menschen wir
haben diese Angriffswelle gestern hier
in Odessa erlebt gestern Nacht drei
heftige Wellen wir saßen im Bunker wir
haben hier im Zentrum von Kiew heftige
Explosionen gehört und man muss wissen
viele Häuser haben ja keinen Bunker
keinen Keller da verbringen dann
Familien mit Kindern älteren Menschen
solche Angriffswellen einfach in Ihren
vier Wänden und trotz allem erleben wir
immer wieder dass der Wille das
irgendwie durchzustehen trotzdem noch
sehr groß ist der Wille diesem
russischen Angriffskrieg etwas
entgegenzusetzen danke eine für deine
Schilderung und eine hoffentlich
ruhigere Nacht für und deshalb danke
Heiko Maas hat es als Außenminister
erlebt Angela Merkel hat es erwischt
genauso wie Olaf Scholz und Annalena
bärbock ist bereits pannenprofi es ist
nämlich schon das dritte Mal dass ein
Defekt am Regierungsflugzeug ihre
Reisepläne durcheinander bringt diesmal
waren es also die Landeklappen des
Airbus A340 die die Ministerin samt
Mitarbeitern und begleitenden
Journalisten zwangen ein zweites Mal in
Abu Dhabi zwischen zu landen Australien
das erste Ziel der Reise erstmal
unerreichbar Andreas berichtet
für den Airbus A340 der Bundeswehr
Flugbereitschaft ist vorläufig
Feierabend Schluss aus Defekt der Flug
mit der Nummer gaf 891 fällt aus
gestrandet auf dem internationalen
Flughafen in Abu Dhabi die
Außenministerin und Australien müssen
warten wir haben aufgrund eines
mechanischen Problems die Maschine bei
ihrem tannenstopp aus Sicherheitsgründen
nach Abu Dhabi zurückkehren lassen
müssen und derzeit werden die Optionen
für die weitere Reiseplanung geprüft und
geklärt geklärt ist bislang nur der
regierungsflieger war in der Nacht zum
Tankstopp in Abu Dhabi kurz nach dem
wieder abheben merkte Pilot hier stimmt
was nicht die Landeklappen lassen sich
nicht vollständig einfahren die
vorgeschriebene Reiseflughöhe und
Geschwindigkeit sind so nicht erreichbar
das ist zwar jetzt keine absolut
bedrohliche Problematik also in
verschiedenen ab oder so aber sie kann
mir auch der Pilot ja an sagte an Bord
damit nicht weiterfliegen verlängere
Strecken da der Airbus für den Flug nach
Australien Rand vollgetankt ist wiegt er
für eine Landung zu viel gut 80 Tonnen
Kerosin müssen deshalb über mehr und
Wüste abgelassen werden
was ein ganz seltenes Ereignis technisch
und das könnte im Grunde jeder allein
passieren vermutlich ist es bei älteren
Flugzeugen
ein wenig wahrscheinlicheres was
passiert die betagte deutsche
regierungsflieger Staffel hat schon für
etliche Pannen gesorgt 2018 Kanzlerin
Merkel muss auf dem Weg zum G20-Treffen
nach Argentinien Umdrehen der Funkfeld
aus die Elektronik spinnt Merkel fliegt
dann Linie und verpasst den ersten
Gipfeltag ebenfalls 2018 Olaf Scholz
damals Finanzminister strandet in
Indonesien diesmal ist es höhere bzw
niedere Gewalt Ratten hatten
Elektrokabel angefressen
2019 Entwicklungsminister Müller bleibt
in Sambia wegen technischer Probleme
hängen muss teile seine Afrika Reise
abblasen made in Germany hat einen
erheblichen
Schaden genommen in Afrika das wird
natürlich überall berichtet berichten
über Flugpaten konnte auch der damalige
Außenminister Maas 2019 hatte er nämlich
gleich dreimal in drei Monaten Pech mit
den regierungsfliegen trotz all dieser
Hiobsbotschaften das
Verteidigungsministerium wehrt sich
gegen das Image die Flugbereitschaft sei
eine pannenerlein manchmal könnte man
annehmen dass wir von mehr
pannengebeutelt sind als ich sag mal
vergleichbare Airlines dem ist mit nicht
nur so wir sind auf dem technischen
Niveau einer renommierten Airline wohl
auch deshalb wird im September der
betagte Airbus A340 mit der taktischen
Kennung 16.01 außer Dienst gestellt die
drei neuen modernen
Langstreckenflugzeuge vom Typ A350
sollen dann alle parat sein für künftige
hoffentlich pannenfreie regierungsreisen
und inzwischen ist klar dass die
Außenministerin heute Nacht mit dem
regierungsflieger weiterreisen kann und
wir machen jetzt weiter mit den
Nachrichten von Gundula Gause und einer
anderen Ministerin die pannenfrei ankam
entwicklungsministerin Schulze bereist
mehrere Länder in Westafrika auch in
ihrem Amt als Präsidentin der Sahel
Allianz darin haben sich mehrere Geber
Staaten organisiert um Armut und Hunger
in der Region zu bekämpfen ebenso wie
andere Fluchtursachen im Gespräch mit
Mauretaniens Wirtschaftsminister geht es
auch um Perspektiven der schnell
wachsenden jungen Generation im Sahel am
Mittwoch wird sie in Nigeria erwartet zu
Beratungen über die Krise in nieder
dort hat die neue militärhunde
angekündigt den abgesetzten und seit
Ende Juli festgehaltenen Präsidenten
basum wegen Hochverrats Anklagen zu
wollen Anhänger der Putschisten gingen
erneut auf die Straßen sie protestierten
gegen die Sanktionen die von den
benachbarten Staaten nach der
Machtübernahme des Militärs verhängt
worden waren
in Augsburg ist der
afd-landtagskandidat Andreas jurker nach
eigenen Angaben Opfer eines
gewalttätigen Angriffs geworden der
35-Jährige habe Verletzungen im Gesicht
erlitten sowie ein Sprunggelenk
gebrochen er sei aufgrund seiner
politischen Tätigkeit zusammengeschlagen
worden erklärte die afd-fraktion im
Bayerischen Landtag Polizei und
Staatsanwaltschaft bestätigen diesen
Zusammenhang bisher nicht und ermitteln
nach tagelangen heftigen Regenfällen
sind im Norden Indiens mindestens 49
Menschen bei Überschwemmungen ums Leben
gekommen nach mehreren erdroschen
stürzte ein hinduistischer Tempel ein
allein dort starben mindestens 9
Menschen nach weiteren Vermissten wird
gesucht zahlreiche Straßen und Dörfer
stehen unter Wasser es ist Monsunzeit in
Indien Wissenschaftler rechnen mit
weiteren massiven Regenfällen
auch in Norditalien haben starke
Regenfälle einen Erdrutsch und
Schlammlawinen verursacht menschen kamen
nicht zu Schaden mehrere vermisste die
sich in einem überfluteten Wohnmobil
aufgehalten hatten wurden von
Rettungskräften gefunden am schwersten
betroffen bardoneckia etwa 90 km
westlich von Turin mehr als 100 Menschen
mussten den Ort verlassen die Behörden
hatten rechtzeitig vor den Wassermassen
gewarnt
es ist ein schleichender Prozess von der
Öffentlichkeit weitgehend unbemerkt
immer mehr private Investoren übernehmen
Arztpraxen um damit logisch Geld zu
verdienen einerseits gut denn es fließt
frisches Kapital ins immer Klammer
Gesundheitswesen Abläufe werden
digitalisiert moderne Technik
angeschafft
andererseits steht über allem der
Profitgedanke möglicherweise auch über
dem Patienten wohl
Gesundheitsminister Lauterbach spricht
nun von giermedizin auch wenn er selbst
den Weg für den Einstieg privater
Investoren ebnete Britta Spiekermann
berichtet aus Berlin
Franz Meyer ist Finanzinvestor er kauft
in Deutschland Zahnarztpraxen 100 sind
es schon es sollen noch mehr werden
milliardenschwere Rückendeckung hat er
von einer Investmentgesellschaft mit
Stammsitz im arabischen Steuerparadies
überein
wenn man es gut macht lohnt es sich ja
das ist wie bei vielen Dingen im Leben
man muss es gut machen dann funktioniert
es auch ob sie eine Bäckerei haben oder
ob sie eine Zahnarztpraxis haben wenn
sie es nicht gut brauchen es ist kein
gutes Geschäft das zahnärztezentrum in
München Nymphenburg ist so ein gutes
Geschäft hier ist Dr Wolters angestellt
das heißt für sie geregelte Arbeitszeit
und keine lästige Bürokratie den Vorwurf
der gewinnhabe in einer Investoren
betriebenen Praxis Priorität bestreitet
sie für den Patienten bleiben alles beim
Alten er kriegt alle
Therapiemöglichkeiten aufgezeigt
individuellen Gesprächen das war so und
das ist so und ich ähm meine Person kann
sagen dass das
Wichtigste in meiner beruflichen
Tätigkeit ist und sich meine Moral nicht
verändert hat
in Regensburg fernab der scheinbar
schöne neuen praxiswelt warnt Professor
Helbig Direktor der Klinik für
Augenheilkunde vor einer gefährlichen
Entwicklung zu ihm kommen die Patienten
die seiner Meinung nach zunehmend durchs
behandlungsraster fallen da gibt es
verschiedene Beispiele das sind zum
Beispiel Schieloperationen bei Kindern
die nicht lukrativ sind wo es schwierig
ist Termine zu bekommen das sind aber
auch Patienten mit Behinderungen das
sind demente Patienten die halt sehr
aufwendig in der Betreuung und in der
Pflege sind die ja in keiner Weise
vergütet wird und die sind natürlich
nicht das worauf sich Finanzinvestoren
spezialisieren werden das Problem
verschärft sich wenn der Markt von nur
wenigen beherrscht wird die Augenarzt
Kliniken sondern optisch und Artemis z.B
haben in manchen Regionen in
Schleswig-Holstein und Bayern
mittlerweile monopolartige Stellungen
auch andere Fachbereiche sind betroffen
die Dialyse ist quasi in privater Hand
besonders begehrt bei Investoren die
Radiologie das
Bundesgesundheitsministerium brauchte
lange um wach zu werden der Gier so
Lauterbach müsse Einhalt geboten werden
Investoren mit hohen Rendite Erwartungen
mit hohen Gewinnerwartungen das müssen
wir untersagen doch der für Anfang des
Jahres angekündigte Gesetzentwurf liegt
bis heute nicht vor an der Uni Bielefeld
forscht man zum Thema das
investorenkapital im Prinzip willkommen
aber wir müssen aber in der Regulierung
darauf reagieren und müssen Sorge dafür
tragen dass diese Entwicklung eben nicht
zulassen der Grundversorgung geht und
deswegen müssen entsprechende Garantien
von vorne herein bei der Vergabe von
sitzen auch mit vorgesehen werden die
Kassenärztlichen Vereinigungen sind
eigentlich dafür zuständig die ambulante
Versorgung für alle zu sichern aus Sorge
von Investoren fordern sie reflexartig
mehr Geld man sollte die
Niedergelassenen Praxisstrukturen
Stärken ausführlich finanzieren dann
gibt's auch keine Gefahr dass diese
Praxen von heuschre cken aufgekauft
werden das Gesundheitswesen lockt
Anleger milliardenschwere
Beitragszahlungen und die demografische
Entwicklung garantieren Gewinne aber tut
das den Patienten gut
vor ziemlich genau 11 Monaten starb in
Iran eine junge Frau Massa Amini nachdem
sie von der iranischen Sittenpolizei
verhaftet worden war weil sie ihr
Kopftuch angeblich nicht
vorschriftsgemäß trug was dann folgte
waren Massenproteste gegen das
mulareschingen es kam zu
Straßenschlachten zwischen
Demonstrierenden und Polizeikräften
mindestens 20.000 Menschen wurden
festgenommen mindestens 7 hingerichtet
viele
Oppositionelle haben Iran seit dem
verlassen aber nicht nur sie vereinzelt
flüchten auch Angehörige der
Sicherheitskräfte weil sie den radikalen
Kurs der mullers nicht mehr mittragen
wollen Kamran safarian hat einen von
ihnen getroffen
er war Mitglied einer Spezialeinheit der
iranischen Polizei Omid 27 Jahre alt
hier in seiner Uniform er wird bei
regimekritischen Protesten anfordern
in Demonstranten hinein so wie bei den
Protesten gegen gestiegene
Lebensmittelpreise vor fünf Jahren
auch bei den Unruhen im letzten Jahr
schlagen Milizen Demonstranten nieder
Schießen auf sie erstmals spricht Omid
jetzt über seine Zeit bei Irans
Sicherheitskräften
wir wurden ausgebildet die Menschen in
Angst zu versetzen wir sollten
Demonstranten auseinandertreiben sehen
Ecken drängen um sie festzunehmen zu den
Aufgaben unserer Einheit gehörte auch
auf protestierende zu schießen auf die
Augen und andere empfindliche
Körperteile
Omid sagt er selbst habe Befehle
verweigert und habe nicht geschossen
doch er weiß Demonstranten wurden schwer
misshandelt
festgenommene wurden fast zu Tode
geprügelt ihre Hände und Füße über Kreuz
zusammengeknebelt und sie wurden an
unbekannte Orte verschleppt wo ihnen
unmenschliche Dinge angetan wurden
schon länger hatte er Zweifel war nur
auf Druck seines Vaters zur
Polizeieinheit gegangen er wechselt die
Seiten und geht bei den Regime
kritischen Protesten im letzten Jahr auf
die Straße mit seiner Vergangenheit habe
er abgeschlossen sagt er
sollten Dinge tun die gegen die
Menschlichkeit gerichtet sind das konnte
und wollte ich nicht mehr
ich habe daraufhin den Dienst quittiert
mein Vorgesetzter nannte mich einen
Verräter
das hat Folgen Omid wird festgenommen
geschlagen sein Vater kauft ihn frei er
muss unter tauchen so wie ihm er geht es
vielen Protestierenden das Regime setzt
weiter auf Einschüchterung Präsident
raisi droht Frauen ohne Kopftuch
inzwischen öffentlich mit hohen
Geldbußen oder gar Haftstrafen will das
Regime jetzt das kopftuchgebot
Durchsetzen das Regime möchte durch
diese Maßnahmen den Status Chor ante
wiederherstellen die Uhr wieder
zurückdrehen die Frauen wieder
einschüchtern aber ich denke dass dies
nicht gelingen wird weil wir in einer
neuen Zeitrechnung in Iran sind es gibt
sehr viel zivilen Ungehorsam und die
Frauen lassen sich in meinen Augen auch
nicht mehr einschüchtern
auch für Omid wird der Druck größer er
flieht im Mai über die Balkanroute nach
Deutschland auch aus Angst vor der
Todesstrafe in Deutschland hat der
politisches Asyl beantragt doch das
Regime verfolgt ihn weiter
dann hat mein Vater mehrfach unter Druck
gesetzt gefragt wo ist ihr Sohn wieso
kritisiert er das Regime und begeht
Geheimnis Verrat
ich habe große Angst dass sie meiner
Familie etwas antun
will auch von Deutschland aus für die
Freiheit der Menschen in Iran kämpfen
und hofft dass sie dort wieder auf die
Straße gehen
und jetzt geht es hier weiter mit
Nachrichten zunächst aus der Wirtschaft
und mit Gundula
die Immobilienkrise in China verschärft
sich erneut zentral sind neue Zahlen des
Immobilien riesen country Garden der
Aktienkurs stürzt ab eine mögliche
Pleite setzt Chinas Wirtschaft weiter
unter Druck Frank Widmann da geht es um
einen Giganten auf dem chinesischen
Baumarkt wie massiv ist die Krise dieses
Konzerns sie lässt aufhorchen vor allem
weil gerade dieses Unternehmen lange
Zeit als finanziell stabil galt aber
letzte Woche konnte country Garden eines
der wichtigsten und größten
Bauunternehmen Chinas fällige
Zinszahlungen für Kredite nicht mehr
leisten und jetzt tickt die Uhr
innerhalb von 30 Tagen müssen die Gelder
gezahlt werden sonst droht im September
die Insolvenz die unternehmensschefin
spricht von den größten Schwierigkeiten
seit der Gründung des Konzerns auch
andere große chinesische Baufirmen sind
in Bedrängnis ebenfalls dramatisch
überschuldet der Bauboom seit den 90er
Jahren ist vorbei wahrscheinlich die
Baukonzerne und die chinesische
Regierung darauf keine Antwort zu finden
auch hierzulande schwächelt der
Bausektor wie beunruhigend ist die
Entwicklung auf dem heimischen
Immobilienmarkt naja vorweg in China ist
die Situation sicher noch dramatischer
aber auch bei uns ist der Bauboom
begünstigt durch billiges Baugeld vorbei
auch in Deutschland häufen sich die
schlechten Nachrichten gleich drei
größere
bauträgergesellschaften sind in
Schieflage geraten kämpfen mit der
Insolvenz schwierige Zeiten für
immobilienkonzerne auch hier an der
Börse die hier gelisteten wohnovia LED
und THG haben enorme Wertberichtigung
auf ihre Immobilien vornehmen müssen und
die Banken müssen sich auch weitere
Kredit Ausfälle einstellen
vielen Dank für diese Einordnung
die erste Runde des DFB-Pokals hat dem
frischen Bundesligisten Darmstadt 98
eine überraschende Niederlage
eingebracht 0:3 gegen viert legist FC
Homburg der damit in der nächsten Runde
steht weiter sind auch die TSG
Hoffenheim und Zweitligisten Magdeburg
zu wenig Bewegung keine gute
Stressbewältigung eine aktuelle Studie
der DKV bescheinigt der Mehrheit der
Deutschen einen ungesunden Lebensstil
die Wissenschaftler warnen vor einer
drohenden Gesundheitskrise auch mit
wirtschaftlichen Folgen
besorgniserregend vor allem zu langes
Sitzen jede und jeder Deutsche Sitze im
Schnitt 9,2 Stunden am Tag noch einmal
eine halbe Stunde mehr als zu
pandemiezeiten Experten raten zu mehr
Bewegung ausgewogener Ernährung und zum
Verzicht auf Nikotin und Alkohol
der
Ätna ist wieder aktiv der Vulkan auf
Sizilien hat erneut Lava und Asche
gespuckt vergangene Nacht war eine Lava
Fontäne auch aus weiter Ferne zu sehen
nach Angaben des nationalen Instituts
für Geophysik und Vulkanologie dauerte
der Lava Überlauf einige Stunden der
Betrieb am Flughafen Catania im Osten
Siziliens wurde bis morgen früh
ausgesetzt der über 3000 Meter hohe Etna
ist der größte aktive Vulkan Europas
was wäre gewesen wenn eine Frage die
jeder von uns kennt was wäre gewesen
wenn man die Jugendliebe geheiratet
hätte wenn man an einer bestimmten
Stelle im Leben anders abgebogen wäre
wenn ja wenn das ist die Frage die über
dem Film past lives schwebt und der von
der Kritik als schönster Liebesfilm des
Jahres gefeiert wird denn er erzählt die
Geschichte zweier junger Menschen in
Korea die sich aus den Augen verlieren
und deren Bindung trotzdem nie aufhört
oder doch der Film kommt am Donnerstag
ins Kino Nadja nasser hat ihn schon
gesehen
[Musik]
es ist ein Wiedersehen nach 24 Jahren
ein Wiedersehen nach zwei
unterschiedlich gelebten Leben in
verschiedenen Kulturen und Zeitzonen
Nora und Hesse lieben sich schon seit
Kindertagen in Korea und das Gefühl von
damals ist sofort wieder da
[Musik]
Soul vor 24 Jahren Nora und hey sind
unzertrennlich bis ihre Familie nach
Nordamerika auswandert hey San bleibt in
Korea zurück vergessen hat er seine
Jugendliebe nie
Nora lebt mittlerweile als
Theaterautorin in New York und ist
glücklich mit dem Amerikaner Arthur
verheiratet der Besuch der alten Liebe
bringt ihr Leben durcheinander der Typ
hat sich 13 Stunden Flug aufgebürdet da
werde ich dir doch kein Treffen mit dem
vermieten der Typ ist eine Jugendliebe
und es ist ja nicht so dass du mit ihm
davon läufst
tatsächlich eines Abends neben meiner
Jugendliebe und sprach koreanisch mit
ihm und neben meinem amerikanischen Mann
der nur Englisch kann und wie Nora im
Film fühlte ich mich wie in einem Portal
in dem Zeit und Raum in meinem Leben
verschmolzen
[Musik]
gibt es ein Wort
enion
das bedeutet vorsehen oder Schicksal
aber es bezieht sich ganz speziell auf
Beziehungen zwischen Menschen
und glaubst du daran das Sagen Koreaner
nur um jemanden rumzukriegen aber
tatsächlich schwingt bei ihrem
Wiedersehen immer die Frage mit sind sie
eigentlich füreinander bestimmt wie wäre
es gewesen in einem anderen Leben
[Musik]
ich hoffe dass der Film unter die Haut
geht und ganz offen ein paar
Lebensfragen stellt denn jeder geht ja
in die Geschichte hinein mit seiner
eigenen Lebenssituation und einem
eigenen Liebesleben und für jeden wird
der Film hoffentlich etwas ganz Eigenes
bedeuten
past life in einem anderen Leben ist
liebevoll und einfühlsam erzählt einer
der schönsten Filme des Sommers
gucken wir uns an oder hier geht's auch
weiter mit Kino und dem Road Movie
Paradise Highway Straße der Angst mit
Juliet binosch und direkt danach um 0
Uhr meldet sich unsere Kollegin Laura
barnick mit unserem heute journal Update
und wir sagen bis morgen wenn Sie mögen
schönen Abend
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter ja mit der schwül
heißen Luft und der Luftmassengrenze
quer über Deutschland bilden sich
heftige Schauer und Gewitter das ganze
verlagert zwar sich zwar Richtung
Nordosten aber hauptsächlich über der
Mitte findet das Wetter Geschehen statt
schauen wir uns die Nacht an da gibt's
über der Mitte quer Richtung Osten
schauen und Gewitter teilweise nehmen
die ab neue kommen dazu ganz im Süden
und im Norden da ist es größtenteils
trocken Temperaturen sinken auf 20 Grad
im Osten und im Südwesten das ist eine
tropische Nacht am coolsten Nachrichten
Alpenrand weil 14 Grad morgen dann
weiterhin quer über Deutschlands teils
heftige Schauer und Gewitter im
unwetterbereich mit starkregenden Hagel
und Sturmböen und dann zum Abend kommen
aus den Alpen heraus neue Gewitter auf
die sind dann auch im unwetterbereich
und es ist eine schwere in der Lage
möglich ganz im Norden bleibt es trocken
Temperaturen dazu Maximalwerte bis 33
Grad im Osten hier Hersteller extreme
Wärmebelastung heiß wird es auch ganz im
Süden bei 31 Grad am kühlsten noch an
der Nordsee mit 23 Grad die nächsten
Tagen bleibt diese Luftmassen Grenze
bestehen quer über Deutschland verlagert
sich höchstens leicht nach Süden
Temperaturen 21 bis 31 Grad Freitag
sogar bis 33 Grad und damit ein schöner
Abend